Larry I'm wondering if you can tell us
the first screenplay you've ever sold
and what was happening in your life at
that time the first screenplay
I sold was Beetlejuice and I had been a
screenwriter with screenwriting I was
also working as a story analyst I was
Union story analyst local 8:54 I still
have my card in case all else fails and
I worked all around I mean I worked at
every studio in town and I I was working
at Paramount I was as a story analyst I
suffered a real case of writer's block
and I had a chance to audition to become
in a studio executive for Jeff
Katzenberg and Michael Eisner I saw that
as sort of a doorway out out of
screenwriting which I was feeling very
up in the air about and wondering if I
could really do it and I became a
student secretary for a couple of years
at Paramount and then I went to work for
Walter Hill the great director Walter
Hill as his head of development and
there were a series of incidents that
made me realize that I was giving away
my best ideas and giving away my talent
in a way I was no longer comfortable
with and I wanted to go back to
screenwriting and
and I formed a partnership with the two
Michaels as I refer to them the late
Michael bender who was my producing
partner and the late Michael McDowell
who is my Beatles his writing partner
and we wrote Beetlejuice on spec and
finished it and I had taken a reduction
in salary and gone back to script
reading to support us will support
myself and my family well while we were
writing Beetlejuice and so that was the
first that that was the first one and
when it was finished I had a very good
relationship with a very prominent
studio head who shall remain nameless
and and when Beetlejuice was finished I
gave it to him to read on a Friday and
he said I'm happy to read it and I got a
call on a Monday that he wanted to meet
with me and I thought oh my gosh you
know he read it he must love it or he
would not be summoning me to his office
so quickly and I went into his office
and he said to me Larry what are you
doing he said you have actually a very
good future as an as an executive as a
producer this piece of crap is going to
sink you and sink your career why would
you put this on the marketplace
representing you and he said it's weird
it makes no sense it's not commercial
and I left that meeting as you can
imagine a to say to say a little taken
aback a little would be putting it
mildly he could not understand why I
would want this bizarre piece of junk
representing me and but I had also given
it to because I've taught for like 25 30
years
primarily at UCLA and I was teaching a
story analysis class at that time and I
had a student named Marjorie Lewis and I
thought she was the smartest young woman
in my class and she had a low-level
development job at the Geffen company
and I'd given it her to her to read only
to see what she thought because I really
had learned the value of her opinion and
so coming out of this meeting feeling
very bad about myself
I called Marjorie and I said did you
read it
she said yes I read it and I said did
you like it and she said like it I'm
going to get the Geffen company to buy
it and and knowing Marjorie
what she did was that she just put it on
people's desk and she was so tenacious
and she was so annoyed that people who
finally said okay we'll read it will
read it and and that's how it got to the
Geffen company and that's how I've got
read and Marjorie is probably like I
said probably one of two unsung heroes
of that and and and the Catherine
company proceeded to buy it for our
asking price on my god which was
incredible and and on it went and we can
talk more about that experience as you
wanted to be I'm wondering the timeframe
from when you had this epiphany or this
thing that happened when you said I no
longer want to give away whatever it was
your advice or your wisdom and your
talent in this manner anymore from when
you were in more of an administrative or
executive type role yeah and one is it
how what was the timeframe from what
then when Marjorie finally got it to the
gas and company well I had uh might when
I when I went to work for Walter Hill I
left paramount I went to work for Walter
Hill
in the Phoenix company and and Walter
was one of the producers of alien the
first alien film and Anna's partner and
my my two bosses David Guyler was
another one of the producers and when I
went to work for them one of the first
things I said to me one of the primary
things that your job is going to be is
to find us a writer for the alien sequel
and I and without going into detail
certain promises were made to me if I
found that writer good things would
happen I will just leave it at that and
I met with Jim Cameron and the this that
this is I I I'm going to say I
discovered Jim Cameron for aliens and
that's pretty true but if you had my job
and Jim McCann and this was I believe
that Terminator was maybe in
pre-production or post-its is long
enough I don't remember but Terminator
was was not out there but if you read
the script of Terminator and met Jim
Cameron and you didn't think that he was
going to be the Jim Cameron you didn't
deserve my job so this was this was
hardly like a great insight on my part
you just met met Jim and he was a force
of nature and you could just feel the
talent but it still was a hard sell
because he had he had a not very good
movie called piranha to that that you
know that I had to show people and this
was back in the day when you had to set
up a projector and you know it in office
and and hope all the light wasn't
bleeding and and but I just but anyway
that it was it was a bit of a struggles
a bit of a fight but Jim not only became
the writer obviously but the director of
alien
and I went to my bosses and said okay I
think I did my job I think I not only
brought the writer to the project I
brought the director to the project look
what I did and they said yes he did so
what and it was enough I I just felt and
I'd had an experience at Paramount with
a film called young Sherlock Holmes
which was a regional idea of mine and as
an executive there we were under so much
pressure to bring in ideas that I did
something I told myself I was never
going to do because I sort of had a
little file of ideas that one day if I
write again I'm going to write and that
was one of them and I brought that in
and there were a lot of promises made to
me if that got made great things would
happen and it did get me the written by
Chris Columbus and I I just I just
realized and also I just I was a writer
I mean that's who I was and I'd let that
go and I had myself to suffer a classic
case of writer's block and and I just
said I'm going to be a writer again and
I got I got very blessed having my
partner Michael McDonald who was as
professional a writer as I'd ever come
across and working with him it inspired
me challenged me made me understand what
it truly meant to be a writer and
screenwriter and a screenwriter with a
career and I and women went and and the
the epiphany was actually I don't want
to I want to be a writer again and I'm
just kind of selling myself short and
selling my talent short by not doing it
and get over the fear and and do it how
many hours a week were you working
before and then once you said you took
did you say you took a script reader job
and I hear down yeah I mean when I was
at Paramount we we worked seven days a
week there's stories about Jeff
Katzenberg and his work schedule that
people think are apocryphal maybe
they're not
there there would never be a job in
Hollywood that I would be afraid of
after working for Jeff he was it because
we worked seven days a week 14 16 18
hours a day and and he was a very
demanding boss but he was a great boss
and I developed an enormous amount and
having never gone to college never had
that experience III felt like I was in
the most brilliant film school in the
world having that job and again
incredibly demanding in terms of time
and and and just feeling like you never
left the office but it was it was it was
a boot camp but it was a great boot camp
but I was also and and I wasn't writing
then not because I I didn't have time to
write I could always have found a half
hour every day to write but I just
didn't think of myself as a writer
anymore but when I was when I finally
started writing with Michael McDowell II
started writing Beetlejuice I would do
my my day job fit it in and then Michael
and I would work I mean and you know and
we'd slide him Howard to a day and then
we got some financing where I could
leave behind the script reading we could
focus on Beetlejuice maybe this is a
good story for aspiring screenwriters
out there when I when I went to work
with with Michael McDowell on
Beetlejuice we had been working for a
couple of weeks and he sat down and he
said Larry this is not working out this
is not happening and I was taken aback
and I said why what do you mean he said
because you're just sitting around
waiting for inspiration and I don't work
like that
I'm not I'm not going to sit around
waiting for you to be inspired if you're
going to work with me and Michael was
this professional writer as I
men he had published I don't know 1920
novels or novels genre novels he had
written for a show called tales from the
dark side he was the real deal and and
and and and not a not not a pro not not
a person to to hold back his feelings
okay any any and again he said to me
this is just not happening and and he
said and this was the most this change
my my life as a writer he said if you're
going to work with me look at it like
we're working in a bank we get in at
9:00 we have a cup of coffee we say good
morning we then we go to work and we
were and we write until lunch we go have
our lunch we come back we write again
till around three o'clock in the
afternoon we fold up the writing we
return whatever phone calls whatever
business of writing we have to do and we
do this five six days a week and we ran
and it's a job it's not you sitting in
it with a metaphorical beret in a
metaphorical loft waiting for
inspiration to strike it's a job and it
was a bit of tough love and it took me
aback and and I suppose a tiny bit
offended but then then the thing he said
to me that sealed the deal because I
when I was working at Paramount I was
writing script notes again it was it was
like a 16-hour day often and in probably
fourteen of those hours a day with
writing script notes and he said Larry
you've told me you've written hundreds
of pages of notes for other people's
scripts why can't you do it for yourself
and I was like wow okay I will try it
your way and it changed my perception
who a writer is what a writer does and
it changed my work habits and it changed
everything and I did it his way and I
took all of that all and he was
absolutely right all of that discipline
that I'd put into other people's work I
put in I started putting to my work our
work and and and and it was and and the
Elton's came out of that and is crazy
and you know and as far out of that
movie is the script was written in a
very disciplined way because that was
the way Michael needed to work
Larry why do you feel that beetlejuice
old why did that screenplay sell in your
opinion yeah you know this is gonna
sound so pretentious maybe but when when
I decided I was going to be a writer
again and decided I was going to do
Michael in my mind I said to myself
sounds so awful maybe but I'm going to
write a classic well I'm not just going
to write another movie we are going to
create a classic and who knows what that
means and again it sounds obnoxious
maybe but we knew probably I don't know
20-some pages in that just something was
happening and we weren't thinking about
demographics we weren't thinking about
who the audience was going to be we
weren't thinking about any any
quote-unquote commercial aspects of it
we were thinking what's good what's
funny what's making its laugh what's
moving the story forward what are the
zany as craziest ideas we can have and
it just and it happens with with with
scripts and it happens in your writing
there's just times that you feel that
you're in a zone and you're in a place
that you're so connecting with yourself
and you're so
connecting with what your vision is that
if you can get on a page other people
are going to see it and feel it to do
and that movie was was that and we
didn't know what was going to happen
with it when when the movie was finished
there were people Warner Brothers in the
marketing department who absolutely
hated it they wanted to change the title
the house goes and dump it and back in
the days when you'd put it in a thousand
this' or something and let it run a week
and then hopefully it would go away
that wasn't everyone and we had David
Geffen on our side so we were protected
but it was hardly loved but I knew who
we were writing it for and and in my
mind and it's very 80s reference there
was a band there so bad The Cure the
great cure and I loved and I had gone to
see them at the Rose Bowl huge concert
maybe fifty thousand people and it felt
to me like it was fifty thousand teenage
girls in black yeah you know right you
know and and and that was and and that
when in a writing character Lydia came
out of that and I always that I thought
that's who the audience for this movie
is and as we were writing it and and I
that for me and it may have been
different for Michael but that was
always who I thought this movie was
being written for and and it's really a
family story and it's about a girl who
needs a mom and a dad and and and and
because her real mom and dad just don't
understand her don't spend enough time
with her so she ends up with two ghosts
that's the heart of that movie and
that's what I was riding towards and the
must and that so so finally its release
and I go to see
at a nearby river city now at Universal
on a Friday night it's the first Friday
night and I watch it with an audience a
real audience for the first time Chris
Urban some test audiences and all of
that
and people are coming out of it either
loving it or hating it which I thought
great that's exactly what we wanted and
that was that was Friday night then
Saturday night I went back and I saw a
bunch of teenage girls who had gone into
their closet having seen it on Friday
night and came back dressed like window
writer Lydia deeds and I thought okay
it's a hit we have connected with the
audience to the point that they're
already dressing up as Lydia and then
there was a marketing meeting at Warner
Brothers it may have been on the monday
and it had surpassed everyone's
expectations in terms of the grosses and
and the audience feedback and it was
obvious that that would that it was
going to take off and be something
special and again in in this no-name
zone about mr. na there is a marketing
person who I always remember as a guy
who would wear a scarf no matter what
the temperature was okay and and and it
was a I remember Tim Burton being there
and David Geffen being there and the
Michaels and myself and this marketing
person all he could say all he could the
best he could do was well at least we
got the little girls in black to come
see it and we walked out of the meeting
and Tim said well who that acted we
think he made it for ya do you think we
made it for and and it was just it and
and one thing when things are going well
in my writing
and I think it's true for all writers
that if you're like intensely
self-conscious about who is your
audience who who is it you know is this
for the 12 to 16 year old if you're
doing that you're not writing well and
you get in a zone and your story starts
telling you you're not telling the story
it's emerging from someplace within you
and that's what Beetlejuice was and I
just always had that and I used to say
to Michael sometimes because I could
feel it going well and I'd say Michael
you know we're going to have a toy
lining he'd go shut up shut up
just finish the script yeah but I I mean
it's a very hard thing to explain what
that what that what that it's it's an
epiphany after an epiphany and that you
feel like you're just onto something
bigger than you you know well going back
to the other no-name person yeah
then did they ever reach out to you here
they kind of put you in a spot where
you're almost on alleged metaphorically
and then you're just elated with
validation that this worked even though
maybe you didn't totally expect it but
did that person ever reach out to you no
okay no biggie it because that would
have required a certain amount of
humility and a certain willingness to
say you know what I on this one and not
everyone has that ability is there a
specific kind of story a first-time
screenwriter should write
yes and what what what that story is and
and you know it's not that cliche right
what you know because I've never written
what I quote unquote know I write
fantastical worlds and and and and and
supernatural stories and all of that but
write what you feel and write what's in
your heart and write something that
means something to you and you know I
was a script reader for God probably a
decade and I and the and and I was
reading seven eight scripts a week and
the rare one was the great script and
when you found that that was a very
exciting day at the office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were funny
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really innovating as a script reader
who's sitting there and asked to read a
script synopsize that write a comment
about it then pick up another one and
read it and it's not were the ones that
you could tell were written by people
who were looking at what last year's hit
was and trying to imitate it and those
were deadly and they were they weren't
good they weren't bad they were safe and
mediocre and any writer any young writer
any old writer anyone who's just
starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart and and and people may not
think that Beetlejuice is a personal
movie it's an intensely personal movie
it was intensely personal for Michael
and me and and you know I I didn't know
I had a theme until I had enough work to
realize I had a theme and almost
everything I've written are about broken
families who are put back together in
some bizarre way but there but because I
came from
broken family and and what and and and
so so the there's a I like to think that
my work has a sense of heart in a sense
of compassion and a sense of humanity in
it no matter how bizarre it is no matter
how weird the world's get and and you
got you got to write something that you
feel on something that you have some
passion for or just why do it it's too
hard it's just it's not an easy job and
and I personally can't imagine saying
well this was a hit now so I'm going to
I'm going to write my version that I
don't really it's not really what I care
about what I feel but I can imitate it
well enough I can't imagine spending a
year of your life doing that but people
do it all the time and they usually
write me do Chris Krebs is being safe
something that's never appealed to you I
I don't know how in in in in my career
and in my life say safe hasn't factored
into it and and not not always not
always the best decisions maybe but I'm
just I sort of like jumping off cliffs
what's the first step in writing a
screenplay there's there's there's just
there's an idea and usually what I know
is I know it been Beetlejuice for
instance the idea was that I discussed
with my partner's a psychedelic ghost
comedy we had no idea what that meant
but it rolled off the tongue right and
and and and I usually have something of
an idea like that and I kind of know the
beginning and I kind of know the end
the middle is the great unknown but but
but but it's it's an instinct an idea
and sometimes it's a character and
sometimes it's a situation but it's very
it's very internal at first and and and
yes there's times where you write an
assignment you know and and and you're
you're you're given an idea and say
translate this into a movie but in terms
of my my own my own writing if you will
my my personal writing it usually comes
through out front from just the most
basic kind of idea and a feeling you
know and and and it's like and I can't
articulate it very well I'm sorry
because it's hard to articulate but it's
just kind of like again like a situation
in our character that's just kind of
waiting to come out and then you
whatever you whatever your process is
and boy do you need a process and boy do
you need to go to work and boy do you
need to sit down and do it and do the
job of writing and and and you allow
that that character of that situation to
just start growing and sort start coming
you know leaving your fingers on to the
digital page these days you know on your
computer and then it grows and expands
and it takes on life and and you know I
there's of course and this is that this
is every writers choice there's a lot of
talk about backstory always you know
like like tell it you know where did
your character go to school how you know
what was his or her mommy like and all
of that I've never written a backstory
in my life never but if you ask me to
tell me the backstory one of my
characters I could I'd kind of be making
it up as I went along but the feelings
would be true because I feel I I feel
the characters
and I feel like they need to come out
and I feel like they need to be given a
voice and and that's just that that
that's that's what writing is to me a an
idea or a character or situation or an
emotion or a feeling that that you
somehow have to put into the world and
it's hard to articulate it and I feel
like I'm talking in circles but I but
it's it just it's almost hard not to
because it's so it's so ephemeral in the
beginning you know I I hope that makes
some version sense it does and I and I
so the middle it sounds like is
undetermined but you know and ending
when you start so I kind of know
anything I kind of know anything but
that can all change but people get very
scared of the middle but for me that's
when it gets fun because it's so
challenging and you so get to what you
know in the screenplay if you think of a
screenplay is 110 120 pages you get to
page 60 and you go oh my god
I'm only halfway there what happens next
but but something will happen and and I
and that's exhilarating and it's
exhilarating to go to bed completely
sure that you will never figure out
what's going to happen next and wake up
with the answer and that and it and it's
you know it's it's a it's it's a daily
challenge but it's a it's so it feel it
feels so good to realize that that next
scene will be there if you keep working
at it there's there's it's the best
feeling in the world other than
finishing and then finishing it's like
the first draft no matter what shape
it's in as like brilliant I mean that's
just I always
get tears in my eyes when I finish a
first draft because I feel like I'm
saying goodbye to a group of people that
I'd been on this journey with and and
and there's of it there's a very
emotional side to it and then you know
then you become the craftsman and time
for a second draft and all of that but
it's it's an it's an emotional journey
and to do that day after day it's it's
incredibly rewarding and I've got the
best job in the world so let's say
you're 60 pages in yeah and now you're
kind of like what do I do next
so keeping in the vein of not waiting
for inspiration yeah and and you're
treating this as a job it's like working
at a bank you know so what's happening
let's suppose it's 9:00 a.m. Monday
morning your 60 pages in you've got the
cup of coffee and you're there and you I
will go back I will never go back to the
beginning because that is a deathtrap I
know what I'll do I'll go back and
rewrite the first 60 pages and then I'm
not going to rewrite the first 60 pages
again and again I'll go back and read a
couple of pages and and maybe do some
cosmetic stuff just to get you know just
to put myself back into the zone of the
story and then you just and then I just
start writing and they may not be good
ideas there may be my drafts are always
2030 pages too long
when I finish the first draft because
I'm telling the story to myself uh but I
I forget who it was I'm going to say
Oscar Wilde I'm gonna say son famous
writer said just sit down and start
typing your name over and over even
Oscar Wilde made the pre typewriter I
bet but the you understand the point
start typing your name start doing
anything with your fingers and I and
again it's it's like where that comes
from
and where that next scene comes from
it's there
it is there and if you put yourself in a
position to find it you will find it and
I might spend a day writing ten
basically bad pages but there will be
one page of truth in it and one one
moment that will move the story forward
and and Stephen King talks about this
really brilliantly and he I have
questions about outlining and I'm not
here to have an outline debate he's
scathing about outlining if you've ever
read his book on writing great probably
the best book I'm writing ever written
into my mind but he always says it's
what happens next it's what happens next
what happens the next one happens next
and you know if I were to reach across
the room here and and steal your pate
your notes from you there would be a
response that or if I were to kick the
camera over and say I'm done with this
interview there would be a response
right and then it's what happens next do
you jump on me and I could say give me
my notes back you jerk you I mean and
it's really that it kind of gets it and
if you just look at it like that that
that and you look at it like like
whatever whatever you may happen
something has to happen next and that's
what happens next what happens next what
happens next what happens next that what
happens next will come and it may not
come easily and there may be a lot of
like I said bad what happens next before
you write find the right what happens
next but it'll come and it's it and it's
it's a magical process I mean magical in
the sense that that it's almost
unexplainable
and it's why and it's why there's so
many screenwriting programs and apps and
and and all of these things out there to
kind of tell you that they can tell you
what happens next
but they can't tell you what happens
next only you can tell you what happens
next
and I look at as a moment-by-moment
process and I put these characters in a
situation and it's often diabolical and
it's often otherworldly and they've got
to get themselves either deeper into it
or get the hell out of it and that's the
journey and it's moment by moment and
it's and it's it's sort of literally
second-by-second if you think about it
you know movies move forward in a linear
fashion and it's just in it and it's
just tracking that and and and and
putting your character and and when it
really gets fun is when you put your
character in the most difficult can I
tell you a quick anecdote that that that
is probably the an illustration that I
use about this all the time I'll tell
you a quick story about what happens
next but I'll tell you when I teach the
very first class I always say and I make
this statistic up depending on how I'm
feeling the room uh I will say
ninety-eight percent of you will fail
and people go oh and I say you'll fail
because you'll never finish you will
never finish your script and and sad but
true I'm not wrong I'm pretty darn close
and I'm taught hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of students at this point and
not finishing is exactly what most
people will do I just have I've just
been teaching a workshop where I've
given people 12 weeks to finish a draft
that they've been working on for a long
time and the dropout rate is enormous
and this is exactly what you said this
is perfectionism and this is a not
allowing yourself the ability to fail
and it's a huge mistake you have to you
know baseball metaphors get tossed
around a lot
in the screenwriting trade because they
kind of fit in a way like if you're
batting 300 you're doing great but that
means you're hitting the ball once every
three times right and and and and but to
go back to this what happens next idea
and how I you know and you as you had
said you wake up a Monday morning with
your cup of coffee and you've gone to
work and you have no idea what what
needs to happen next in your script was
a story I tell about this almost always
in my classes was from Beal Jews where
there's a scene that a lot of people
love actually it's become like a lot of
people one of their favorite scenes and
the ghost Barbara Barbara Adam Geena
Davis and Alec Baldwin they died they've
driven off a bridge trying to avoid a
dog aren't they good people they tried
to avoid the doggie and they drove it
off a bridge and they drown and they're
trapped in their house now as ghosts
and they've been given a book about how
did the handbook for the recently
deceased that they can't make that they
can't figure it out and they want to go
into the afterlife and ask questions
about how to be ghosts and how they're
supposed to live it you know live as
ghosts as dies goes whatever and and but
but what my code my writing partner
Michael McDowell I had done is we
trapped him so well in their house we
had no idea how to get them into the
afterlife we had done a very good job of
sticking them there what would what felt
like no exit and we had to come up with
a way for them to get out of the house
and the dynamic between you yet you got
to understand Michael was I'm going to
say harvard-educated if not Harvard some
incredibly prestigious university I I
grew up in a trailer park and barely got
out of high school okay but there was
there was there was a sometimes it was
usually usually playful but sort of a
status issue between us and and the way
we'd often work with
that I would like vomit out ideas and he
would just start shooting them down and
it was always one word no no no no and
we were trying to come up with a way to
get them out of house Barbara and Adam
the ghost get them into the afterlife
and I was coming up with more and more
convoluted ideas about how to get them
out of the day house and I'm sure trying
to bring out my supernatural chops and
all that I knew about you know
metaphysics and blah-de-blah
just to get them out of the house and
every idea I came up with no no no and
my ideas kept getting further and
further out and more convoluted no no no
and I finally got really angry with
Michael and I said Michael what do you
want them to do draw an effing door and
I just said it because I thought it was
a stupidest idea imaginable and I was so
mad ice is that what you want you want
them to draw door and he just started
laughing and I started laughing we said
yes that's exactly what they should do
is draw a door so rather than these
incredibly like these convoluted
supernatural nonsense Adam found a piece
of chalk drew a door drew a doorknob
opened it and went into the afterlife
simple but it took all of that
convoluted stuff to get there and that's
what will happen when you sit down and
you're stuck you will write and write
and write and you won't think you found
it and you'll know you haven't found it
but if you keep at it and you keep
writing they'll finally be that epiphany
moment and you'll go oh that's what
happens next and then you will write
that and you will have moved your
characters forward one more step in your
story and then the next what happens
next is in front of your eyes and you
move forward like that and it's
sometimes it's literally moving an inch
or less than an inch at a time and
sometimes it's running sometimes it's
crawling sometimes - what happens next
happen really quickly and you
you have a day where you just go oh my
god you know I just you know I just
wrote ten great pages and all they need
is just a little a little sprucing up
and they're there and some days you will
write 10 pages and you will have maybe a
quarter of a pages usable but you will
have moved the story forward that much
and it's it's a kind of alchemy a kind
of a magic of creation but it's such a
beautiful feeling it's best job in the
world give a feel writing a boring story
no no I know I do mean fear that defines
here define here right well I think I
think for some people you know it sounds
like you're okay with not being perfect
but I think for some people that's their
whole sort of persona maybe they've been
told it all their life maybe that is a
class thing or I mean yeah but that's
their Ella that's who they are they live
in that world that I do everything right
so then they don't want to do stuff
that's wrong but it sounds like if
you're willing to be free and make
mistakes then boring doesn't really
enter the picture I not yes and and and
and that's it I'm not afraid of being
boring because I I just I I will jump
off creative cliffs and I and sometimes
I'll land were really hard and break my
neck
and sometimes I'll land exactly where I
need to land but boring isn't an issue
for me and it's interesting because I've
been at this a long time now and I feel
more unborn than ever I feel I feel
creatively Unleashed
some of it is I have nothing to prove
I've got some cool posters and a couple
of classics and all of that but I'm not
I'm not ever worried about boring I am
worried about good
and that's a different thing and good
that it's going to resonate and and and
that people are going to feel it and
that's a different thing not but not
boring but being good I worry about
every day when I write and I'm very I'm
I'm my hardest harshest critic and
sometimes that gets in the way a little
bit
I I wish I could go to bed not analyzing
and reanalyzing what I wrote that day
but maybe that goes with the territory
but yeah I always wanted I want to be
better than good
and and I wasn't you know and again it's
sort of silly and maybe arrogant as it
sounds and like when I was starting
Betelgeuse with Michael we're going to
write a classic I want everything I do
to be great and you don't always do that
I'm not even pretending that you always
do that but good isn't good enough ever
for me and boring doesn't enter into it
so when you see a student let's say that
you can tell that's maybe something they
need to get out of that rigidity what
tips do you have for a writer that or to
help them avoid writing a boring story
because maybe they're too too perfect
you know yeah and and and it's and it's
you're yet what that's so that's so true
that students writers knew I'm going to
say new writers
that sense of perfectionism in that
sense that they have to get it right the
first time and went went when I when I
teach their third people within this
room who can attest to this back when I
teach I am the home of TMI I come in and
vomit everything going on in my life be
a good bad tragic happy I I am I am an
open book if I'm being completely honest
because it's free therapy and I have a
captive audience of 20 people okay but
it's also because I care here when I
went to one of the great sages and of
all time and with a view of the human
condition Jimmy Page from Led Zeppelin
said said I never want to be respectable
I always want to be responsible and I
love that quote and I hope after the
first class that people take with me
they know they're not going to get
respectable at all I can I will I will
again I will tell too much and there is
a little bit of method to my madness
though because because I don't want it
because I know writers directors who put
themselves on that pedestal because I'd
had this degree of success and they feel
that they have to come in and be very
button-down and very above the people
that they're talking to or talking down
through I don't look at it like that at
all I will tell you
about my bad night my hangover my
whatever but but and part of it again
it's like free therapy but part of it is
also this is this is my life in and
where and it sometimes it's not terribly
respectable but I'm responsible because
I'm responsible because I will get my
ass to my computer and right and don't
worry about being perfect but that is a
debt that I wish I could say that that
my success rate was a hundred percent
with that but again most people will
never finish their scripts because that
sense of needing to be perfect
oh I'm being boring oh this isn't good
at this isn't working it will take over
and it will crush their creativity and
it's a very sad thing the witness I try
to get people over it I try to say look
it's a first draft I tell you no don't
worry so much but but that is the
toughest job any person who's teaching
any kind of creativity has is to
convince people to get out of their own
way and my way of doing it again is to
say today students I am a hot mess but I
wrote but I but I wrote for four hours
and then they feel okay they're all so
imperfect but whatever sort of front
were all we know we all have our public
image that we put up it I think that's
great because or if it's really good
well they feel superior to it yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean yeah but I know that
but again it's some of it it's just a
nature of my personality but some of
it's very deliberate I just don't you
know I I you know I've knock wicker I've
made a living at this for thirty years I
mean it's insane sometimes great
sometimes just skating by sometimes
whatever but it hasn't come out of being
perfect believe me but it's coming out
of
of having that enough discipline to ride
always don't need to be respectable
always be responsive me Paige let me pay
Wow thank you what are a few of the
things you do to try to get people out
of their own way in terms of teaching
and writing in that regard one thing
that I love doing when I'm doing
workshops is having like a free write
and I will pick something a topic
something that's happened to me that
week or or something that's that's
either like making me really happy or
really bothering me to be in the world
it can be personal and all of that and I
will ask people to write just like let's
spend the first half hour of the class
just writing about that and and that
could be I was on the phone yesterday
and before I knew it I was saying things
that I really regret and I couldn't take
back have you have you been on the phone
and said things to someone who you
really care about that you really regret
and and you can't take back and of
course everyone has and people will
write and because again I I will be sort
of ruthlessly honest with myself it will
give people permission to be honest with
themselves and and and some of the most
amazing writing I've had come out of my
workshops are those free rights and and
and it's and it's writing there's going
to be so much rejection there's going to
be so much indifference there's going to
be there's going to be so so many people
saying no other people do
you don't do that you know other people
make movies you don't make movies I was
I was with a very talented writer
director on Sunday night who was from
Georgia and was talking about when he
said to his family he was moving to New
York to make movies he said I might as
well been saying I'm going to Mars to
colonize the red planet you know I mean
no that's what other people do that a
kid from Georgia doesn't do that and and
I just try to convince people that that
just relax oh my god relax just writed
don't worry about it yeah some people
will hate it some people will love it
beetle to beetle just got a lot of
terrible reviews they were wrong I I was
told by one of the most prominent
executives in Hollywood I was ruining my
career he was wrong people but what what
so what if they're right you'll write
another one and and and I and I love
doing free writes I love saying reveal a
little something about yourself this is
a safe place and it's amazing what comes
out if people give themselves permission
to do that but it's hardly a perfect
process and and so many people will be
so afraid of how they're going to be
judged by their words on a computer
screen for god sakes it's a screenplay
okay it's a f'n screenplay get over it
you know I mean but they will be so
afraid of how they're going to be judged
and how they're going to be judged of
failure that they'll just quit and
they'll figure out something else to do
so I try I try and I try to just loosen
people up and say feel it is feel free
to fail I started surfing again a couple
years ago after after 40 years of not
doing it and I was a really good surfer
40 years ago and I started again I was
tear
I besides everything I thought I knew
you know I knew it in principle but I
had to learn again and then all of a
sudden I started getting good again but
it was after a lot of falling off a
surfboard and embarrassing myself but
but it's it's it's that it's that same
thing you fall off you fall off you fall
off and then you don't and that's and
writing is you're going to write badly
and write badly and then you're going to
write good Larry do you remember the
first time that you pitch one of your
screenplay ideas to a producer and it
worked yes I do and it was to produce
earning very cross and it was an
original idea of mine and it was and I
found I uh I I've gotten to the point
where pitching comes pretty easily to me
because I've been on both sides of the
desk and I know the drill and I know how
to do it but at first I was incredibly
difficult and it was always like the
sweaty armpit at that you know I mean
like a BL and and as you made I always
worried about what these interviews that
that that what everyone hears is me
stammering yeah I mean but I remember I
remember telling this story
and and he was engaged and he was
listening and you can just iíve had
pitches that I even know everyone had
these two minutes in it's just a slow
death words basically and and you just
want to get it over with and say goodbye
and get out of the room but he was
actually engaged in listening and I knew
it was working because then he started
asking me questions and they and and
they weren't they weren't they weren't
you know the polite here's a couple of
questions now go away
a he actually was curious and was and it
was a great feeling and it allowed me to
overcome a kind of a I I used to say
that I I started teaching so I'd learned
to talk in front of people and now you
can't shut me up because I was I there
was a lot of shyness I had to overcome
and so so so sitting in front of someone
and talking at that point in my life
wasn't easy but I could feel the eye
contact and I can feel him engaged in
the story and again when he started
asking me questions that told me he had
really been listening that was a great
feeling and that made and that made
pitching easier until the next time I
went to pitch and it all went horribly
and I and I've had I've had them go both
ways but I developed a very thick skin
about it now and I you know I a couple
years ago pitch an idea to Russell
Brand's development company when he I
think he's I don't know if he has that
company still but I was told by his
executive it's too far out for a Russell
Brand and I thought it's too far out for
Russell breath I've got a bunch of
ruined how does that happen okay that
one I went away going Wow acid flashback
I guess or something but yeah I would
have got yeah but but so then they can
go but they can go both ways but I just
I you know I I when I developed over the
years is a real sense of humor about
this stuff and I there's a there's a
great philosopher who's been a
touchstone for me forever named Alan
Watts and he once said I don't take it
so it's almost like a riff on give me
pages to be respectable be responsible
but he said don't be serious be sincere
and I think that's so true and I go into
the and I never go into these meetings
trying to con someone or not not tell
them something I don't believe in and
and but and I treat them very sincerely
but I've learned not to take them
seriously because of you because I've
seen people and and I could actually
tell some very dark stories about people
who take have taken this stuff way too
seriously and it's literally destroyed
them
and I you know and I refuse to have a
body count like that anymore in my life
and so you go in and you do your best
and you tell them a story and you think
you believe in it and if it's too far
out for Russell Brand what can I say I'm
sorry you know we talked about earlier
and I hope you're talking about you know
maybe not going to college or not you
know I'm just going to junior college
and not finishing and and still having
confidence and being unable to believe
in yourself even if somebody in the sort
of you know executive suit sitting on
the other side of this really nice
mahogany desks with their arms folded
tells you know you're not ok but but
also knowing that you are where does
that come from because I don't think
that that's is something that's innate I
think you probably develop it over time
wouldn't you say yeah and and it was an
issue for me there's no doubt about it
when it when I became a CEO executive at
Paramount working most closely with Jeff
Katzenberg it was all of a sudden there
was this that this as these bizarre
trends happened and you don't quite
understand where they come from and then
why they go away but all of a sudden
became very important to hire people in
development positions who had a Harvard
education and I was working with a
couple of them
and and and they also went to the school
of Makaveli I guess I had read a reread
the art of war and and and on
strategically on that level they could
kill me dead okay but I thought about it
and I thought I've loved movies since I
can remember and while I was terrible in
school I was a terrible student my mom
loved reading and she taught me a love
of reading so I had that on my side but
what I really had on my side was if I
loved the movie I loved a movie I loved
it
and if I and I realized pretty quickly
that the movies the movie business it
was not a business meant for Harvard
grads and I could read a script and say
this is a movie and say it was as much
confidence as possible and and mean it
and believe it and I add but I was up
against this I this this and my own
inferiority complex sometimes about not
having been a good student and not
having you know barely gotten out of
high school it would work on me
sometimes but one day after I'd been
completely creamed it in a development
war with with one of these Harvard grads
Jeff Katzenberg took me aside and he
said Larry you need to learn to be a
straight player in a crooked game I'm
not here for you to out manipulate
anyone you're sitting with me and you
have in your sitting beside me here
because when you love something you love
it and when you read a script and you
love it you're going to make sure that
you that that everyone else loves it too
and and that's what I like in you and
that's why you're valuable to me stop
trying to be a studio executive be a guy
who can read a script or watch a movie
and get excited the way you get excited
and that that was a huge shot in the arm
of confidence that I that I took away
and I I owe Jeff Katzenberg gratitude
for a lot of things that he wouldn't
even be aware of but that was a big one
because he told me just be yourself and
use his passion for movies in this love
for movies and make that your calling
card don't try to be a player you're not
good at it
you're horrible at it which I am because
I wear everything on my sleeve ask my
wife yeah talk about the good bad and
the ugly of writing meetings so how does
a writer personally contribute to the
success or failure of a pitchman or
maybe it's not really within their
control but they feel they've
contributed to it you well you do
contribute to it and and it's really
grossly unfair to having been on the
other side of the desk having been a
studio executive it's it's everyone has
pitch nightmare stories and they're true
but it's really unfair to development
people in studio executives assume that
everyone in those meetings is there to
make basically make your life miserable
and say no to you it's not true and and
wait and how you contribute to it as a
writer you come in with an idea that
you've actually thought through and that
you have some passion for and that and
that
and and that also you need to be willing
to listen it's a conversation and and
the control you have of the conversation
is you're the one coming in with the
idea you're the kind of you're the one
coming in saying hey I think this would
be a great movie this would be a great
television show whatever and you should
have thought it through
and you should have prepared well enough
to when they say well why do you think
it's such a great idea to be able to
answer the questions and you should know
enough about your story that that you
can do it justice in the room but then
having sat as an executive I've also
been in those meetings where you say to
someone yeah I get it but and the
immediately what but there is no but
this is the story you have nothing to
say to me and and a defensive 'no scope
and that's a huge mistake you don't
don't go to the meeting just write the
stupid scrub it's a conversation it's a
dialogue and don't assume that you know
more than the person in the room who
you're speaking to have it as a
conversation and be strong and no-one
you need to dig in your heels and know
that that they're there that if people
are changing your story in the room so
much that you don't even recognize it
anymore which could happen that you need
to say no and say thank you for the
meeting and leave but engage in the
conversation have a little bit of effing
humility for God's sakes you know you've
been invited into the room that tells
someone a story you don't don't don't
assume that they that they don't have a
thought in their head and there are so
many stories and again a lot of them are
true and I could tell you nightmare
stories about pitches we could stay here
all night and I can tell you those
stories but it's but I could also tell
you great stories with great development
people
who have given me enough rope to hang
myself then said that what if this
happened or that happen and they've
given me a better idea at a better take
it's a dialogue it's a conversation and
it's part of the it's part of the
business and I hate to call it a game
but I will for a moment it's part of the
game but if you just can't stand the
idea of going in and telling the story
and someone's going to try to change it
or have an idea write the script
don't be a pitch monkey be a
screenwriter so then how does a
screenwriter keep their side of the
street clean so whatever happens on the
other side of that desk whether the
person is kind with their suggestions or
not how do they keep their own integrity
and ññ poise and all of that by having
an integrity and knowing that you you're
going in with something that you believe
in and that you're excited about and so
if they completely don't get it or say
stuff that you think has nothing to do
with what you've just pitch with them
you know within yourself that the story
you went into tell is the story that you
want to tell and you really believe it
could be a movie and you can really be
excited about it integrity integrity is
an inside job and if you if you're
looking to have your your integrity
brought to you by Hollywood oh my god no
but no it is it's it's it's an inside
job and I if I go in to pitch a story I
I don't do it unless I believe in it and
and and I may be wrong I may be wildly
wrong but I won't leave going well you
know what I thought I'd put that one
over on him but they didn't you know
that
that you know they but they didn't get
it but oh well I mean I'll go I told
that story I could and then you let it
go you just let it go it's a good
meeting it's a bad meeting but you did
your best and that's an inside job and
it's a learned experience too and you
will come out of meetings wondering who
you are and what you're going to be when
you grow up
I still have meetings like that but but
most of the time I come away feeling
good yeah that was my next question I
had add because oh it sounds like you
just have to go through it have a few
where you're like basically in the fetal
position when you go home and then it's
less so you're just on the couch and
then yeah and then they can walk around
the block
yeah and I I don't end up in the fetal
position much anymore because I I
believe in what I do
does mean it doesn't mean anyone else
has to believe in it but I believe you
but it sounds like it was it's a learned
thing and that there's no there's no
magic answer no no there's no there's no
magic answer and again it's one of those
things that I've seen people get crushed
yeah in these meetings crushed where
they can't come back again and that's
again that thing about having an over
developed sense of perfection
perfectionism to say it more simply that
will will be your worst enemy you had a
bad meeting i I was in a that there was
there was this this time where
everything was supposed to be based on
Joseph Campbell remember those days and
everything you had to go in you know and
and and that was what you were supposed
to that was what you were you were
always if you were going to pitch you
were you were going to you were going to
you were going to pitch something in
Joseph Campbell was going to end up in
the sentence and I was going in with a
producer who said now remember to get
the Joseph Campbell moments in there and
I was pitching I was about three minutes
into it and the guy across the desk said
oh Jesus Christ can we
get over the Joseph Campbell stuff can
you just tell me the story and the
meeting died a horrible death and I
should never have done it I should have
just said here's the story and if you
see me Joseph Campbell in it good for
you but but those are those things don't
don't trick yourself just go and tell
the best story that you can a Twitter
question yes we had a question come in
on Twitter two days ago and we'll we'll
leave the person's name off just in case
they don't want it there but I'm sure
they're ok with it but they just asked
I'd like to know how one secures a pitch
meeting with executives or production
companies as a first-time screenwriter
and then they followed it up with I mean
does one just make a call and set a date
and time do you go in with a treatment
or dot dot dot and there's more of it
but so ok I'm thinking yeah that's that
that's that's a that's quite a question
how do you secure a meeting you write a
screenplay and you write a really really
good screenplay and the metaphysics of
getting a meeting after that are so
elusive sorry
I'm not and it's a very sincere question
on that and I it gets asked to me all
the time and I'm going to dance around
it a little bit but I'm going to but
again not seriously but sincerely there
was a time when I was teaching and that
here's something about me me as a
teacher I am AI I I'm a screenwriting
teacher who's not a failed screenwriter
I'm actually a successful screenwriter
who teaches at the same time
that was cheap I apologized but I I
stopped I stopped teaching at one point
because I really have an ethical dilemma
because I thought the real reason people
were taking my classes is to say to me
how do you get a movie made you've
gotten movies made you've gotten through
the door how do I get through the door
and I could have been teaching anything
I could see story analysis screenplay
structure dialogue anything I thought
the real reason that people were there
was to ask me Larry Wilson how do I get
a pitch meeting how do I get a movie
mate
how do I get through the door and I
didn't know what to say I didn't know
what to say and I felt like I was like
part of this false hope machine and I
didn't like it and I didn't like the way
it made me feel and I stopped teaching
and the thing that brought me back to
teaching and where I could do it again
were a question like that which I wish I
had a great answer I I looked I I've
been blessed by the fact that doors open
unexpected doors open for me my entire
life after I moved to Hollywood I was
working in a department store stocking
makeup because I'd worked because I'd
cleaned my mother's beauty shop for
years and I knew how to stock makeup and
the woman who loved the way I stalked
her makeup said oh it's oh you want to
be in like the the entertainment
business well you should do cue cards
and she introduced me to a man named
Barney McNulty and the next thing I knew
was I was doing cue cards and all the
biggest television shows of the time a
door open I can't explain why that
happened
why went in stocking makeup in that door
open luck and all of that it's too
complex of a question but and but I knew
it was what people were asking I hope
this is making sense I know that's what
people were asking me really how do I
get through the door
how do how do I get my script read by
someone that matters well there's some
easy Pat answers to that they're not Pat
but you know there's there's contest
there's pit or geezers all you know
these millions of things out there that
you need to be careful about what you
submit to but there's all those ways
that there is no answer the question but
the and I got very I really start I had
an ethical dilemma about it I did not
want to be trafficking in false hope and
then I had some magical answer so the
first part of the answer is write a
really great scrub but the reason I was
able to come back to teaching was the
digital revolution and the fact that you
could make a movie holding up money cell
phone ladies and gentlemen you can make
a movie on your cell phone now you can
make a movie for a thousand bucks there
is no excuse for you not to make a movie
anymore and knowing that and knowing
that I could go in and help people write
a great screenplay and that they and no
one would give them the time of day they
could figure out how to write a great
screenplay that they could shoot for 500
dollars on their iPhone inspired me to
come back to teaching and the answer is
there is no answer the answer is you you
put yourself in every possible place
conceivable place you can think of
without getting ripped off by sham
screenplay contest and all you put
yourself in every conceivable place you
can think of you submit your script
anywhere you possibly plant can you talk
to anyone who you think might be able to
help you and maybe that door will open
for you but if none of that works make
your own movie sorry you know I I and
and and I am and it's it's it's a great
place to be but it's a scary place for
people to be when I started in in the
business a billion years ago making a
movie was expect just a film stock could
stop you from making a movie the cost of
printing and developing and dailies and
all of that could stop you from making
movie that wasn't that people didn't do
it but is incredibly difficult but
the digital revolution if you can't get
your stuff seen if you can't get a pitch
meeting shoot a film shoot shoot a
10-minute short and post it on YouTube
take your career and your life into your
own hands and stop waiting for these
gatekeepers to give you permission to be
a filmmaker and you can at the same time
you're trying to get through that door
and you're trying to get that pitch
meeting and you're trying to get that
huge movie off the ground do all of that
but be making your your iPhone movie be
and and and it's an answer that people
don't want to hear why why do you think
they don't want to hear it because it
puts all the responsibility on them it
makes them it makes them have to make a
movie
it makes them have to do something in
public and perhaps fail it makes them
have to go to their mother and say can I
have a thousand bucks mom why well I
want to make a movie if you think I'm
going to spend a thousand dollars I I
mean you know it's it just puts all the
responsibility back on you as a
screenwriter and a filmmaker and people
hate that they want that ticket that
that is going to open that door and I
wish I had an answer I have struggled
with that question for decades of
teaching and I don't know why these
doors opened for me I don't know I know
I was persistent I was idiotically
persistent I literally was that that
doofus who went around to the guard
gates at Studios and said I want to make
a move how do I make a movie sir you
know to a to a gate guard I mean I
literally did that because I was so dumb
I didn't know any better but one of them
finally said to me well son what do you
do well I read will then become a script
reader how do I do that well he asked
someone and I got a child $75 a week
reading scripts and it was and then I
got it you know and then I was like
working you know and a cosmetic counter
and a make
Annie and I and I you know I mean it's
just stupid stuff that that's the way
life works or doesn't work for you but
the whole the whole landscape has
changed where anyone can make a movie
now what that means is there will be
millions of bad movies but make sure
yours is a good one and you know and and
God here build it and they will come or
whatever that is so that's the best
answer I can give and it's not I wish a
question and asked her I could give you
a better answer but it's the only answer
I can honestly give you because I don't
know let's talk about some faulty rules
of writing the old adages on writing
that really don't apply today yay and
let's maybe we use stars okay well well
you know you talked about you know
Joseph Campbell's a hero's journey and
it's still hear him speak in these
YouTube videos it's a magical experience
it's not the norm at all but I'm just
wondering if as a teacher there's
classes that your students have taken
previously that run into you certain
adages that really don't apply I mean we
know what what is it writing is
rewriting but that seems pretty rigid
yeah it sounds like that's true yeah so
something similar to that and I'm not
sure what else II okay
there is a huge business maybe an overly
huge business in teaching screenplay
structure a three-act structure of five
extra you know and and and there are
there are I I know I know a fair share
of screenwriting gurus who are at each
other's throats all the time about which
structure is the structure and I'm not
saying there's not a structure
be in big trouble I said there wasn't a
structure and that a story didn't have a
beginning a middle and an end
but this reliance the this absolute like
like need to follow any structure map
that's out there and if you're and if
you don't have a turning point on page
30 you haven't done it right or if
you're on step 5 of 22 steps and you're
on the wrong step you haven't done it
right or any of this stuff it's not true
this structure business it's a business
and I can't guy and you need a diagram
petite structure and you sell a diagram
and it's very it's very hard to say I
have the best diagram unless you have a
diagram right I mean you need a diagram
to sell a diagram I told you earlier
about my diagram that ends on pages 60
with someone hanging themselves it's an
emotional diagram it goes like this it's
like page 1 oh god I can do this this is
going to be great this is best story or
page 10 oh my god I can really do this
everyone was wrong about me my parents
can go s themselves I'm a writer on and
on emotional and then like about page 20
you go oh god this is really getting
hard and sorts in the grass starts going
down and down and then again you get to
page 60 and like I'll never finish this
you hang yourself it's my structure okay
it's an emotional structure it's an
emotional diagram but wait sorry to
interrupt but what happens after the
hanging man dies oh well you you go into
despair for a while you put yourself to
bed then you wake up and you start again
and it has a happy ending okay and at
the ending there's big bags of money all
the sex you ever wanted power but you
know you win right but
it's obviously tongue-in-cheek
and add to make a point but but but the
real point of it is is that have
characters who you believe in and you
believe that you can write them and that
they are in some sense writing you that
they're coming out of a place of truth
for you put them in the tightest most
impossible situation you can imagine and
get them out of it and know that you
have probably need to do it if you're
writing a screenplay in a hundred to one
hundred and twenty minutes and let the
story flow and there will be natural
points within you doing that where you
will feel that the story needs to go
faster needs to go slower that that that
there needs to be more drama there needs
to be a moment of rest all of these
things that structure teaches you and
again I'm not saying there isn't a
structure but those structure diagrams
they can be as an assistant or they can
be a cage hmm they can be an absolute
cage and they can trap you and there is
if you believe that you that you're a
writer you have a natural storytelling
gift that you need to honor that you
need your respect er don't be a writer
I mean don't don't think that you can
tell a story if you don't feel that you
have a natural storytelling gift and you
can't tell when things are going too
slowly or things are going too fast and
just let it flow and then go back and
see if it's structured right but this is
another thing that will stop people dead
in their tracks over and over again is
your first act is too long who cares who
cares you'll figure that out the writing
is rewriting in the rewrite and and and
watch a lot of movies read a lot of
books I am now because of
of constraints of time some time I'm on
podcast junkie I hear the most brilliant
stories in podcasts and stories that
have a natural beginning a middle and an
end because they're true just embrace
all of that embrace the movies that you
love take them to your heart and if
you're a storyteller the story will
emerge and it will merge with the
structure let's talk about all of that
answer it does yeah yeah and I'm
wondering is there anything about the
business that's sort of a fallacy we see
you know this in the same vein so you
talk about I'm struggling for what one
would be but where you have this saying
that's not really true I okay so again I
want to say that there are a lot of
really terrific development executives
out there there are a lot of great
producers I've worked with some truly
great producers I worked with Scott
Rudin on on the Addams Family for for a
couple of years you've never been a
producer live work with who understands
story more deeply than Scott Rudin and
Scott Rudin and when I run and when I
wrote that and so in my Carroll with my
partner Caroline Thompson one of his
greatest gifts was he let us fail over
and over again even finding the idea for
what the movie was going to be so there
are great they're great development
executives there are people who
understand story who will help you with
your story
but but there are also people out there
who who are development executives who
never written script never made a movie
what are they going to use to come in
and talk to you about they're going to
use a structure they're going to use a
structure diagram they're going to read
the same book you read and they need to
have set have something to say to you to
justify their jobs
they need to have something to say to
you to bring you in and say you know
what as your as your development
executive I'm telling you that your
first act is too long well where are
they getting this information from
they're not getting it from movie god
they're getting it from the same book
that you read and so and so like all
self-reinforcing systems a structure
structure guides and structure diagrams
become their own truth that everyone
buys into and pays homage to until
someone doesn't and someone breaks it
all apart and does something that's
innovative and doesn't follow any of the
rules and then those become the rules
can I recommend a podcast since we're
talking about pausing half there's a
podcast with six parts you can binge
listen to it called inside psycho and
it's about the making of psycho go your
wherever you get your podcast and listen
to the development of that movie that
classic movie that is now considered one
of the great movies of all time and
where it started and what the
powers-that-be thought of it and you
will see how wrong people can be and
anyone who is who is holding up your
story that you're telling to a graph and
saying it doesn't fit the graph
therefore it's a bad story watch out
they may have a point
you may need to get cut to the chase and
get in maybe the first act is too long
but if they're holding it up to a graph
and that's all they know how to do you
need to look within yourself and say am
i telling the story right not as a
structure guide telling me if I'm
telling the story right I hope that sort
of answers because it almost reminds you
of Jimmy Page smashing a guitar
basically sort of like
you know being maybe I wasn't the first
one to do that and and yeah but it is I
mean and again it's that that allow
yourself to fail the first time it allow
yourself to tell the story the way the
story emerges from you and if you're a
storyteller the story will emerge and
you have to believe you're a storyteller
how about the old put it in a drawer for
a month and then come back to it once
you're finished with the screenplay
ah very true for me and again I always
bow to the wisdom of Stephen King and
it's something he does and if you get
his book on writing maybe the only
writing book you'll ever need until I
publish mine he talks about that process
and how he puts it away and is there's a
brilliant final chapter of that book
where he actually shows you after the
story had gone away for a while the
edits that he did write but but I put it
away because what I find is that just
getting from beginning to end you're so
immersed in it you're so you're so deep
inside of it in some in some funny way
you don't know what you have and what's
an amazing experience is you go back and
reread it you go did I write that you
didn't remember writing it was just like
really good and it has nothing to do
with the whatever chemicals here in
Jesse when you're writing it just has to
do with the the process of it it's a
fascinating thing but then what what I
will do is I will take it out of the
drawer and my drafts tend to be really
too long because I'm explaining so much
of the story to myself in the draft in
the first draft I will that I will do a
radical edit on it I will take as much
out as I possibly can and see and just
like by feel and try to tell the story
if it's a hundred and forty pages I may
cut it down to 110 pages
less that's a lot but then I may go back
and then I'll put it away again but it
won't be for as long it'll be for like a
couple weeks or something then I'll go
back and reread it and see who maybe
maybe I've taken too much out maybe this
does need to be explained but you do but
but the point is however this process
works for you you do need to step away
from it when you can now I've been in a
work situation I haven't animated a new
film coming out Halloween 2017 to a
theatre or digital platform near you the
little vampire an animated movie that I
actually think is good good I'm happy to
say and maybe we can post a link to a
clip some people can judge for
themselves the trailer ready the trailer
is is being rendered and almost ready
what we've seen a cut of it and it's
pretty terrific but that was a situation
that I was in where there was no time
for that and you will be put it because
the work had to go and get to the
animators there wasn't time for me when
there were rewrites going on say well
I'll just put it away for a couple of
weeks and look at it it kind of had to
come hot off the presses if you will you
know hot off the go go straight from the
computer to the animators but and I had
a partner of my great partner Richard
Klaus who we go back and forth but there
wasn't a lot of time now that's a
different circumstance and then you've
kind of got to live with what you wrote
and hope that it works the most of the
time in particularly for new writers
that's stepping away for a few weeks and
then rereading it and rereading where
the fresh eye is crucial
let's talk about one of the most
frustrating experiences as a
screenwriter without you know naming any
names or projects but what it taught you
whether it was about the process
yourself other people working in a group
the most frustrating part look look I
have a very sort of unique and singular
thing that I do and you know start
supernatural comedy and sort of a
surreal take on things and all of that
and I kind of consider myself like
licorice in a way that you either love
it and you eat it or you spit it out but
when I've been frustrated a couple times
about naming names is when people
basically ask me in a roundabout way to
deliver Beetlejuice to them deliver
something that's quirky and
idiosyncratic and and and surreal and I
delivered it and I know it's good and
they're scared of it and they try to ask
me to tone it down and payment to a
point where it loses exactly what they
asked me for it's like you want there is
no next Beetlejuice I'm not I'm saying
this metaphorically or as an analogy if
you will but when people say just be you
just give us straight you and then they
get it and they go oh I don't know and
and and you know and and it my great
partner Caroline Thompson who I wrote
The Addams Family with and Caroline you
know wrote Edward Scissorhands Corpse
Bride I could go on and on with her
credits we've said to each other
ironically sometimes wouldn't it be nice
if we could walk into a room and say
look here's who we are here's what we've
done here's what we want to do
given what we've done could you just
please trust us to do it and and and and
and see what happens but that's not the
nature of it and and so my frustrations
have come when I feel like I've really
delivered something and I'm not going to
name names but there's a there's one
currently that I could I I could go off
a bit if I chose to I chose I choose not
to go off about this stuff and get angry
about this stuff much anymore but where
I really broke my creative back giving
someone something fresh and new and
original and what exactly what they
asked me to do and it scared them and
they ran away from it and that is
frustrating and but there's always the
next one
but you put you know a year six months
whatever it was of your of that much
energy creative energy in your heart and
soul into something and you think you've
given someone exactly what they want and
I'm not I'm not arrogant about my
working that I'm not saying it was
perfect or anything but I knew what was
there was like really there it would
have been good good and they just and
they and they got cold feet and that's
frustrating but you know but then I say
well DIY you know I'll do it myself in
another way and that's the beauty of
what's happened to the business now is I
have that safety net and saying well if
they don't like it if they don't like me
anymore if everyone wants me to go away
they've had enough of Lori Wilson I'll
make my iphone move how they exactly
what I want I think it's interesting to
think about you know and I'm sure
musicians have gone through the exact
same thing when you have these hits and
then people always wanted to go back to
them and make a newer version and can
you talk about the pressure and at what
point did you feel that pressure oh wow
very very distinctly I I got into it was
not you know in problems of the will
to do as my grandma used to say I got
into a position after after beetlejuice
in the add sign whenever just break out
huge hits but people didn't see coming
where I kind of got in that that that
golden trap of where I would be hired
under the and without credit usually not
under the table but without credit to
come in and write a scene or write a
couple scenes for something most of
which never made it to the screen but
I'd get paid a lot of money to do it I
mean a lot of money and that's a you
know and and and and but and and and it
was always that give us the Beetlejuice
scene give us give us Badillo scene give
us the you know the Addams Family you
know the whatever what you know give us
that and and I and but what I realized I
was becoming was I was becoming a hack
and all right I was on the verge of
becoming a hack a well-paid hack but a
hack and I was deliberately repeating
myself for thinking I was repeating
myself for a paycheck well I've had you
know children and my motives are pure I
guess and a look and it's agreed to of
course but I made a break and I a
producer came to me I said I want you to
do something for me and my there's a
script of mine called sleepless Beauty
which sadly has never been made it's
been it's been to the starting gate so
many times it's unbelievable but it's
one of the best things I ever wrote
because the deal I made with the
producer was ok I will do this but
here's the deal just leave me alone for
the first draft just
don't let's not have a hundred meetings
let's let's not do it the typical way
don't ask me to do this do that just let
me write it and it just after after
feeling like I was really headed into
hack dome I wrote this script so fresh
and it's one of the first the only
scripts where we were talking about
putting it in a drawer where the first
draft is basically the draft there may
have been some sprucing up and some
changes but it just came out of me it
just flowed out of me and I realized
again that I needed to be that writer
and I changed my career too much the
unhappiness of my agent in some ways and
my people and I started working a lot in
Europe and I found a way to go there and
and and work because I found a certain
amount more respect I guess for the
writing process and I was thinking to
myself well I can go work in London or I
can go work in Amsterdam or I can go
work in Paris or I can go to Burbank
what will I do
and I refined myself as a writer and um
died and I don't even remember the
question at this point but I I hope the
the the answer is that what I became
again was true to myself sounds like
that's really important it just please
yeah he's important Harry everyone I do
but I think for some people maybe the
comfort and I can't knock that usually
if you know for me I came from very
modest beginning so I could see how
people would want oh gosh I'm absolutely
it's the thinnest town yeah when that's
really how your success is measured yeah
and so but it sounds like that's that's
very important is being able to live
with yourself and your work yeah and not
just for the paycheck and I get
everybody wants that paycheck oh my gosh
yes yeah and you have you
kids and houses and responsibilities and
of course he wanted and and I I I didn't
turn my back and starve my family I
don't want to put it like that but but
but there was a calculation to it also a
career calculation which was whose you
know is that is that that formula whose
Larry Wilson
oh that's Larry Wilson get me Larry
Wilson then get me the next Larry will
so that Larry Wilson is over and I could
feel myself getting to get me the next
Larry Wilson point and again I just I
could feel my the the quality of my work
diminishing and maybe this is the the
the moment to wrap on you you'll tell me
but what what I write is always counted
the most to me because it saved my life
I would not be the person I am if I
didn't have that that my writing I am
I'll I I can I can't imagine what my
life would have been and to and and it's
a it's a place and a truth I need to go
back to to save my soul I mean not to be
overly dramatic about it but it's just
the fact of it and so it so when I feel
that going away and I'm just doing it
just for the money it doesn't work for
me and I have the bank account to prove
which means send money ladies and
gentlemen that's all donations
gratefully accepted
can you talk us through how you make a
beat sheet I don't I I will if
contractually obliged doing a beat sheet
or an outline I will do it and sometimes
you are and what usually happens is you
spend all this time on this beach eating
this outline and it's the most
bastardize thing in the world because
it's not a script it's not a story it's
kind of this thing that exists halfway
between the script and the story and I
will but I'll do it if
you're actually obliged to I'll do an
outline and I'll do a very detailed
outline and I'll do it always to the
best of my abilities I won't slum but
I'll do it and I'll hand it in and the
producers will go we love this outline
this is a great outline now go write the
script and you'll go write the script
and you'll have your outline you'll say
okay here's what the outline is telling
me and you'll start writing and it will
immediately start changing and better
ideas will emerge and the next thing you
know the outline is completely out the
window and you've written a script and
you'll turn it in and the producers or
go
we love this this is just like the
outline and everyone's forgotten the
outline and I don't I know again my
Beach it is I obviously you kind of know
the beginning you know you're putting
your characters and you feel these
characters and you put them in this
situation that they're going to have to
fight for their lives to get out of I
kind of know what the end is going to be
kind of sort of and then it's the great
unknown and to do that in a beat sheet
to me it's just taken all the fun out of
it so don't don't don't listen to me
listen to all the other people out there
who say outline beat sheets please if
that's what you need to do and there's
great writers who do that of course they
do that but and and sometimes when
you're collaborating it becomes more
necessary because you're sending stuff
back and forth but for me I I they don't
work for me and any time I do them
everything starts changing anyway so
much that they quickly become irrelevant
why don't they work for you because that
because I'm a storyteller and and the
stories emerge from someplace that that
that is be cheap proof that's just me I
don't know what I mean they just they
just come from somewhere else and if I
tell it all in a quote/unquote beachy
it's like it's like why would I do that
to myself why would I why would I take
all the fun out of this
discovering it and put it in this thing
that's just kind of bullet points just
but that's me that and that's the
idiosyncratic part of me but I'm in good
company Stephen King my favorite writer
ask him about beat sheets there's ed but
but you know help me the writer who
wrote Game of Thrones the books george
RR martin thank you he said at the best
of anyone he said there are not now you
would think particularly if you've read
the Game of Thrones books that those
things are outlined completely they're
so intricate they're so full of plot and
character and this needs to overlap and
this needs that you know I mean that the
extremely intricate stories he doesn't
outline and what he says about it is and
I think it's such a great quote and I'm
paraphrasing a little bit but it's the
essence of it there are architects and
there are gardeners an architect will
need that blueprint to build what it is
they're going to build
he said I'm a gardener I plant a seed
and I tend it nurse it and I watch it
grow and there are architects who will
do that beat sheet and will do it
brilliantly and and I'm so I'm not
knocking it and then our gardeners and I
guess I'm a gardener I just kind of let
the idea it there and I tend to it and I
do take good care of it and make sure it
gets all the water and Sun and I watch
it grow